hi I'm Ben I'm the teal of Capet this is
pascal who's also been working on it
almost as long as I have so this slides
probably a little bit irrelevant now
kappa'd it's an open-source developed in
the open
tracing replay tool for Julius and
Vulcan it's currently a debugger it can
be used to diagnose and fix many
graphics issues when developing games
we've been using it in the field and
have found some very stupid things that
some of the games engines are doing that
otherwise would be completely hidden
from the developer
it is cross-platform it runs on Windows
Mac Linux and we can use it to trace at
any debug any debug of all Android
application for Vulcan we actually also
support desktop so you can trace up any
Vulcan application on Windows or Linux
obviously not Mac and yes you can go and
download it right now it's on github so
github.com / qø / cap it and then you
can take a look at the releases so
instead of just talking about it it's
graphics after all we might as well show
you some stuff so take over to Pascale
alright okay so when you first launch it
you will see this welcome dialog that
allows lets you quickly do your most
common actions like capturing a Tracy if
I can see the mouse and you know there's
a capture trace dialogue you choose
which API you'd like to trace and trace
OpenGL or you can choose your Android
device and because we're running out of
USB ports we're not going to actually do
a trace if it's also pretty boring you
know you choose your apk your file names
and you have some options and you can
trace file but instead I'll just open
open a trace you've taken previously and
this is a chase of one of Google's only
games sushi
enjoyed at the top you can see that the
frame Stuber captured museum or frame
previews of the frames this is mostly
just a menu see if you can find
something more interesting so the
beginning of this application and on the
bottom on the left side you see all the
commands and we regroup them nicely by
frames and draw calls and if you include
epoch markers in your application you'll
see debug mantras which you will see
right here you know we can you can see
other groupings this is tiny form you
see we can look at and you know you
could step through your your frame and
see how we get spelt up you see all the
track halls that are cooked here and of
course you can see their actual GL calls
as well but I need to this draw call but
obviously you want to also show you some
more if the rest of the state of the GL
drivers so for example we can look at
the geometry that was rendered here so
this is just some leaves sushi here you
can see more interesting geometry and
you can for example the about you know
almost if they don't look okay that's
exactly you can inspect your geometry
that was rendering in this truck oh and
we also allow you to inspect all your
textures and this also will show you
context of texture that our render
targets so which is really nice you know
you don't really need to render your
shadow map on the screen you can just
inspect it here and you have some image
tools like you can disable channels just
again helpful for shadow map so you have
different values and different channels
of course we also show you your shaders
and one of the things we directly you
know to be able to do is rapid
prototyping you know whenever you have
like an issue the shade and you you're
adding a shader right you say but you
save it yeah so we build your
application and you have to package it
up deploy to device wanted just to find
out
you know you forgot that dot zero or
whatever so we allow you to edit the
shaders in place here so let me just
paste something in your data safe before
you say you push your changes and in a
few seconds you can see the the changes
have happened and you know changing our
skybox here to be a nice sunset red and
you can see that it has changed on all
frames you know we've changed our full
skybox would be nice at red we track the
entire state of the the GL driver so you
can inspect it at any point in your
trace you know if you have if you see an
issue and you want to know what was the
blend State at this point at trace you
can go in and sorry inspector trace you
can see the blend State for example here
for vias that you've said it was oh you
know this should be something different
we we also have a beginning for
reporting system that tracks errors for
example gel IRC FIFA if there's a gel
ever going to trace will show it here
for example if there's a and you can
quickly go to the command and see that
this get integer has an interesting
identify that doesn't exist or and we
also planning on having other things
that we can detect and you try saying if
you action or feedback on how you can
improve your game call this about most
feed you try the memory okay yeah
obviously for for some commands you know
like let's just find or something like
it's you know it's it's not exactly very
interesting to see the memory pointer so
we also obviously track them I mean you
can see what what memory was passing and
you can do formatted in the goodbye so
here you can see the matrix that was
passed into this uniform so the the
memory is the sort of power tool but for
any particular plant the Select you can
see all of the memory that was read or
written by that command at that point in
the trace there's been handy for sort of
off-by-one errors so yeah that's pretty
much the tool at the moment a couple of
other things we support multiple
contexts for GL the bar at the top there
it by default selects the most what we
consider the most relevant context for
the particular game but for a lot of the
engines there's multiple contexts that
spun up so you can look between them as
an option as well for an interleaved
context mode so that you can see how the
contexts are talking to each other but
yeah
that's pretty much what we have right
now if there's any questions by the way
please feel free to interrupt
sorry is there a like a high-resolution
CPU time stamp on this sometimes it's
nice to know what you what your codes
are doing CPU side when it's building
the frame currently no we did wanna put
extra metadata and like timestamp
information we're kind of on the fence
about the usefulness of that because
when you do take a trace times are
skewed so having sort of real time
information can be a little bit
deceptive but things like stack trace
information would be particularly useful
just seeing a particular draw call
that's bad
where did that come from yeah so yes
again if you have these suggestions
please forward them to us and we'll act
upon them does the framerate view show
the current render target that's bound
or is it joing what's going to be the
back cover that the frame buffer view
shows what is currently bound at that
point in the trace okay yeah yeah if you
have post effects and things that are
going on off-screen you can debug all
maybe I missed it
what's the requirement for the GPU and
the Android OS supported now is it
doesn't work on all GPU so we see
Android versions okay so in theory it
shouldn't really matter the way that we
intercept at the moment is by patching
the driver and there are some
limitations on what we can patch so we
require a certain number of bytes of
instruction per function we're trying to
tamper with and on certain drivers there
are functions that are too short
coming up in a new version of Android
and coming to you soon is a true OS
support so we won't be doing this nasty
driver patching we will actually have
hooks in the US so we can trace anything
hello is frame buffer floods on pixel
local starts estación supported for we
can examine depth at the moment we
haven't got a VFS Tunsil but yeah we'll
be working on nothing that's pretty
useful for us okay so speaking of what
we're doing out before that just to
mention that the the tool is pretty
modular we have all of the sort of bulk
of the smarts in one particular process
and the UI isn't actually tied into that
at all we have an RPC interface that the
the UI use this to talk to the server
and we have another tool that we
actually ship when you download it
it's called gap it and it actually
exposes a lot of the same functionality
it's been really useful for us
developing you can use it to examine
commands States frames and use it to try
and find GL Paris or Vulcan issues and
we see a lot of value in this in
automated testing in that you can take
trace you can use the command line tools
as part of your
knightly build for example and find
issues in your application that would
otherwise go missing so just to give an
example I'm not gonna type at the
command line
but yeah given the same trace that we
were just demoing you can get screenshot
any particular points we also have the
ability to create an mp4 video of
whatever you have
there's also another mode that we have
where we will capture the frame buffer
while we're tracing and then when we
come to do a validate we can actually
check that the replay matched when we
have um device replay going that could
be particularly useful for variations
between drivers for example oh and my
slide failed
so the current work that we're doing at
the moment for those of you that may
have tried gap it already you may have
been disappointed with the performance
of the tool we are fully aware that it
isn't as fast as it should be and it
takes up too much memory so this is our
number one thing that we're working on
right now make it faster make it less
resource hungry mid execution capture
for GL es is what we've heard people
want lots and lots so we're going to try
and get that out very soon and on device
replay as we briefly mentioned I've
actually used up all the USB ports on
this machine the replay for GL es is
being done on this machine so we
translate from Julius to desktop GL for
replay we've taken that about as far as
we can
Apple refused to push GL drivers any
further than they are and we're now at
the state that GL es is actually
exceeding desktop GL the base port so on
desktop replay just through translation
is actually becoming difficult to
impossible for Vulcan same thing
performance we also want to get the
validation layers and as part of the
report so you don't have to have the
layers in you take a trace and you get
all the same information out and the
final one is an improved UI for
visualising Vulcan data
Volken is a very different beast from
Julius it's not immediate mode you've
got command buffers trying to display
things as a linear sequence of calls is
one way of doing it but it isn't the
best ways that we feel so we're doing a
lot of research at the moment and how to
better visualize these new graphics API
is but you have more of a graph
representation maybe so after that we
have a large collection of ideas of
things that we want to do but we want to
get feedback from you on where we should
be investing our time so I've been
leading this project for a number of
years now and as a teenager always used
to play RTS games far too much so a tech
trees kind of the way that I visualize
my job and that there are many things
that I could be doing and certain things
unlock other things and so the rest of
these slides are going to be going
through some of the things that we can
do and how I categorize them in my crazy
game you burn so there is a
questionnaire that you can fill in as
we're going through this it might be
helpful to play along just so that you
know what I'm talking about when you
have a question if you don't want to
that's fine I won't hold it against you
but yeah if you can open that please go
ahead and the slides will relate to the
questions that come through
that's a question question
is there any timeline for a graphics
profiler for the GPU timeline we'll see
what the feedback is from today and we
we might be able to gather a timeline
from them cool so the the first group
here is statistics I kind of classify
things that don't involve profiling but
still have meaningful values under this
creep so the simplest one which we
probably should have by now is the sort
of Expo why stuff so this is number of
draw calls per frame is like the most
obvious one you're doing 2,000 draw
calls and a device that communicate with
a few hundred you're gonna have a bad
time
so yeah examples of this are obviously
draws per frame vertices per draw
triangles per whatever estimates or
memory usage as well my you know number
of mix of textures that you have we also
want to come up with some sort of device
budgets part of my work over the last
year has been going out to games
companies and trying to help them get
their games reaching 60 and yeah sort of
based on the expo well I think the
number of titles that are being
developed without any kind of reasonable
guidelines on how many draw calls you
should be making for a particular device
is a little bit depressing so we could
offer up some sort of data for a
particular flagship device we recommend
that you submit X number of vertices per
frame for example we could have inside
gap it automatic knowledge of a
collection of different devices and give
you warnings if it notices that you're
way outside those budgets frame buffer
visualizations these are things like
number of over drawers the
doing we can also include things in here
like the number highlighting the
fragments that may have failed a depth
test which would be a good thing or
displaying the frame by shader program
for example which is a great way of
knowing where you should be looking at
optimizing your shaders shader static
and dope yep
yeah overdraw is is part of that yeah
it's coming okay shader static analysis
so this is a tricky one it would have to
be a sort of finger in the air one
because you know there's many different
GPUs out there many intermediate layers
between your shader code and actually
what the shader is doing the hardware is
doing but yeah we can come up with some
rough estimate sort of number of iou ops
to text for example which can be helpful
in just getting a sort of hand-wavy
estimate of what your shaders are doing
profiling big feature requests here so
classic first thing that people think of
is frame and draw counters I've said but
yeah frame and your time would be great
unfortunately tiled architectures make
draw call times very difficult we've got
a few ideas on how we might be able to
come up with some data that would be
useful but yeah knowing what your frame
rate is like or how long yeah knowing
how long certain things are taking is
definitely something that we want to do
if we can also get hardware counters
from the IH fees we would like to try
and massage those huge C's of hardware
counters that nobody really understands
into something meaningful so that we hit
how you you know how much time you're
spending doing Taoiseach fetches how
much time your cache miss
for example something that a lot of the
IV tools offer over things like draw
call times as relative shader costs so
while their tools may not be able to
tell you exactly how long a single draw
called took they take more of the
approach that these are all the shader
programs that you have and this
particular one actually takes that some
of your time so it's where you should be
optimizing this is something that I
think is very valuable and we should
definitely have so assuming that we get
the first two done we would love to have
metrics driven suggestions so if you've
used other tools before in the past they
often suggest have you thought about
changing a vertex format so that you
interleave as opposed to have them
separate these are things that we would
like the tool to actually go and do for
you if we have a bunch of patterns that
the tool can actually detect apply them
to your trace and time them we can offer
a sorted list of things that you could
do to optimize your game ordered by
impact I understand that games
developers their time is precious you
don't want to be spending three days
trying to optimize something to get a
half a percent improvement if we can
show you that doing this one thing will
save you 10 percent of your time we
should do it
another thing that's often forgotten is
power usage and thermals but yet is
really important so if we're going to
give you any profiling information about
timing we should also be looking at how
much power you're using and see if
there's anything that we can do to
suggest reducing the shader debugging
being able to click on a vertex or a
fragment in your frame buffer and have
single line stepping so this is pretty
bug basic but yeah we want to be able to
let you step forwards and backwards have
a watch window
see all the values as you go along
there's a big question here as well
about whether you would value more a
simulation versus real Hardware there
are pros and cons to both if you're
trying to debug something and you're
getting black pixel and it's a driver or
Hardware issue then obviously having a
reference form of that might prove to
you that the actually is a hardware
issue where is trying to pull back from
the actual hardware might give you
skewed results in its own way pixel
history it's kind of part of the
debugging by clicking on the frame
buffer seeing all of the drawers that
influence the color or depth or stencil
and maybe including or excluding ones
that have since been overwritten a table
of shader RINs announced this is more
common for vertex forms that if you've
got one one crazy vertex that's half a
mile across the screen you can identify
that single thing and then go and debug
it and figure out why you've got in for
a noun or something and something else
that we thought about that would be very
nice is if you're debugging a particular
shader highlighting the inputs and
outputs so if you've got textures for
example the assembling in your shaders
actually highlighting the fragments that
are involved in that particular shader
man assuming we can do it it would also
be very nice if you had sort of
anisotropic filtering showing all of the
fragments are actually being used and
then finally we come under the reference
rasterizer
so kind of touching a problem a tile
saying that we have taken the on desktop
replay about as far as I think we can
take it we're now looking at
alternatives so a reference rasterizer
could be very useful for other things as
well as having a guaranteed replay that
you can do on your host machine now the
first one is that we know that devices
do have issues drivers can be buggy
Hardware can actually be faulty and we
I really want to hear about this we
can't stress enough how much we want to
hear about broken drivers we know that
people are having a bad time but we have
to go out and ask you a lot about your
your stories so if he had a trace and
you take it and you're idle we think
that we could do a replay in the
background with the reference rasterizer
nice you checked that what you are
getting replayed on the device matches
what we think it should be and if they
are not the same we can offer you a
one-click report a bug that gives us an
exact repro
so it would be a nice way for the
Android ecosystem to be better all
around Julius in Vulcan they are specs
that have sort of hand wavy aspects to
it especially around floating-point
precision and sampling if we have a
reference rasterizer we think that there
will be value here in having some knobs
that you can fiddle with to basically
compare how things would look on
different sort of hardware specs so the
floating-point precision has the classic
one if you lowered your floating-point
precision do your shaders then suddenly
start providing my zero this is
something that happens and something
that maybe we could catch for you
automatically in a low key on hosts
replay we've got it for Cheerilee s we
would like it for Vulcan as well but
yeah reference rasterizer makes that
definitely possible and more solid than
what we have at the moment and then
finally the automated testing things
this kind of goes back to the gap it
tool if you have a reference and you've
got say nightly builds that you're doing
you could just basically have gap it
automatically take a trace of your your
game make sure that you've got no
bad usage of the graphics api's and you
can also use it to to get a reference
video of what the game should be looking
like and also use the tooling to
actually get videos across the different
devices that you care about and
potentially flag them has issues as they
crop up as opposed to in the last week
of getting the game out and or so that
was a lot of stuff that I just covered
very very quickly if there are things
that I've missed here and you think are
very valuable please please please let
us know and that's it any questions
sorry Mike Fincke you just mentioned
power profiling could you liberate it's
still very much research at the moment
but the idea is that we could have the
ability to replay the same frame
repeatedly and if we had hardware
support for actually seeing the drain
and monitoring the thermals we can at
least come up with a if you keep on
having your game render something
similar to this particular frame this is
the kind of characteristics you're going
to have on the battery in firms and any
of the heuristics that we have for
optimization we can also try that as
well it might be something that you
would have to run overnight to try and
get stable results but it's better than
weeks and weeks of poking around
yourself
you put your all back up the question
here oh sure
finger hearts Marriott
there's Laura kisana where's
here
firth of power and thermals is there
gonna be any way to tie that back to the
core frequencies and the CPU usage so
you can see whether or not there's a
trade-off between your submission of the
call time versus the actual GPU time
great suggestion
yeah maybe these are things that we have
briefly looked at we haven't started
development on so yeah if that's
valuable okay